a lot of people like to post about how
star trek is communism
it's literally not but they don't care
because they're ideologically driven
i mean whatever star trek is it doesn't
really fit the definitions that we
have historically it's just a sci-fi
world of peace
on earth you know not in outer space but
they have replicated technology and they
can their ships
anti-grav and all that stuff and they're
like see that's communism i'm like dude
it's nothing it's star trek it's a
magical universe of fiction
if we want to get to that point it's not
going to be through government
authoritarianism in a command economy
it's going to be through smart people
working really really hard
and people in general coming together to
find new ways to do new things
and unfortunately you know it's
interesting uh ryan long he's the
comedian
he has this new segment out did you you
guys see this i don't know he's at the
church the church of awoke
and he basically is dressed like a
priest talking about how their new
religion is wokeness
and essentially humorously drawing
parallels between
oppressive religious doctrine and
critical theory
that's the freakiest thing to me that
you've got people on the left
weaponizing critical theory which is a
moral authoritarian dogma
which is going to restrict our ability
to actually develop new technology and
do new things
one of the biggest problems i've always
had with the left because i used to do
fundraising for nonprofits
one of them i worked for several
environmental nonprofits
and i immediately started researching
okay climate change is a problem right
global warming is a problem carbon
emissions all that stuff okay
what's our best solution and it came
across nuclear energy
has zero emissions and it has a massive
energy return on energy invested
thorium reactors yeah i've heard thorium
salts right yeah so they're like they're
very safe they don't melt down it's
liquid right
it's a liquid reactor yeah it's a liquid
core reactor there's a
it's it's safer because it it doesn't
you can use the fuel indefinitely it
doesn't have spent fuel rods so there's
not the waste problem like that
other fuels have like we have at yucca
mountain with uh all the reactor fuel
but so so here i am and it's these exact
environmental organizations saying
no to nuclear energy i didn't know why i
said well
it's it's zero emission and this new
technology is safe and they're like
nuclear is bad it's bad for the planet
it's the same reason they took
like an nr mri machine the same way i
talked about edward mills personally
invented nmri nuclear magnetic resonance
so what they use in
an nmri machine an mri machine is called
an
mri machine because they took the n out
it's actually a nuclear magnetic
resonance imaging machine but they
remove the road nuclear because
people hear that word and it's like wow
they don't understand it
but all this is just nuke it's just it's
just the nucleus of an atom it doesn't
mean that it's
it's nuclear uh fission or that it's
nuclear
active decay or radiation it doesn't
mean anything nuclear doesn't mean
radiation it doesn't
so do we know do we need like a uh atlas
shrug type scenario where all the
wealthy industrialists flee to a secret
location to
to be free from the oppressive
government yes we've had a discussion
i think we're all on board with that
making a ranch where we can build
saucers yes and isn't it kind of sad
that
our resources our money is being spent
for destruction
rather than building rather than
actually construction if you look at
where the majority of the scientific
community
where you look at the majority of the
money that goes into them it goes into
weapons weapons not of course helping
creating solving a lot of the problems
that we all face and we have to keep
all of it the technology secret so yeah
everything has to be not open sourced
everything has to be kept for power
purposes and ego
and uh you know it's it's when we look
at it from
the bigger picture it's absolutely sad
and pathetic they've got to be 30 years
ahead
with what we have publicly you know
they're 30 years advanced in some ways
what's
the classified stuff that's out there
and
they're holding that and withholding it
and using it to make weapons and
they want to keep the the whole goal of
this is you know the military-industrial
banking intelligence petroleum complex
and what is what i call it and it's
basically this organization that
of rich people that want to maintain
power and control
in any under any terms possible they
don't and that includes you know keeping
these technologies under wraps and only
for them and for their purposes
there are a few things in this world
that uh
that can break my heart as tremendously
as two specific historical incidents
the first is the burning of the library
of alexandria what a
horror story for human history man that
one just right through the heart huh
one the second though is the quote from
werner von braun
the you know what is he the godfather of
rocketry essentially
and he helped make a bunch of crazy
weapons rocket weapons for uh world war
ii germany
and he has a very famous quote let me
read a little bit they say
when the first v2 hit london von braun
remarked to his colleagues
the rocket worked perfectly except for
landing on the wrong planet
that's so sad man that that that's
that's that's just a punch in the gun
this is a guy who said i want to travel
the stars i want to land on other
planets and rockets can
can do this for us and then a psychopath
took something so beautiful and turned
it into a weapon of mass destruction all
i want is fusion i want working fusion
power i know it's here we have cold
fusion but it's going to create a weapon
it is and it's going to end up being
used to destroy a lot of humans
but what could they do with it if
everyone had one
i don't know focus the energy into a
city so about cold fusion uh
peter hegelstein is a researcher at mit
i went to a cold fusion course they had
an open iap course where you could just
basically anyone from the public can go
there and go to mit and take a course on
cold fusion
for a week and there was all these
professors and all these students there
and that just
came to show up for the course so i of
course went because i live in
you know i lived close enough to boston
i drove in every day
i actually stayed at my my brothers
lives in boston so i stayed at his house
and uh what
explain to us fusion and cold fusion
dude so
basically the idea is that you know in
regular fusion
fusion happens in a star we have the
biggest fusion reactor in the sky we're
trying to we're wasting tons of money on
hot fusion trying to build these
tokamak reactors and and these fusion
reactors here on you know
what does it do like what is the sun
doing it's literally
what's called you know breaking the
coulomb barrier it's pushing
through gravity and other forces it's
pushing these things so close together
that they get so close that through
quantum like tunneling they think that
they're in the same place and they
actually fuse so like a hydrogen
would come together and make a helium
two hydrogens will come together
the protons will add and create two
protons in the nucleus they start
hugging each other and then it creates
the next heavy element and then the next
heavier element
and how does that make energy for us
what does it do it's hot so there's a
mass difference between the nucleus
and uh and there's a mass conversion so
some of that mass is
down converted and then the mass the
leftover mass is actually energy through
equals m c squared and that we can
extract that extra energy that
that's left over through after the
fusion reaction so
what do we do we like we end up with
what like it eventually turns to gold
so it will yeah well actually in stars
the
carl sagan is good a book on this the
cosmos if you ever read cosmos by carl
sagan he um talks about this there's a
documentary on it too um
where he basically breaks down what
stars do we're we're all star stuff
we're all made out of stardust and
everything that all the atoms in my body
and your body and all the atoms that are
here on this planet
were created in supernovas through uh
nuclear fission
i mean nuclear fusion in stars over uh
billions of years and
when they basically create the helium
fuse they create
helium then the helium fuses with
another hydrogen and creates lithium
the next heaviest element and it keeps
going up and going up and going lithium
solid solid metal
it's a solid metal yeah it's actually so
when helium is this invisible gas
combines another invisible gas you'll
get a physical piece of
metal yes that's cool um so there's
different theories on what matter is and
how matter is constructed and how matter
is made
and um of course you know the alchemists
tried to do you know fusion in their
laboratories to
turn mercury and lead into gold right
and um
the idea is that you know if we can
understand
nuclear science then we can create ways
to trick you know these atoms into doing
these things so so what is
cold fusion then that's like i hear
that's like the holy grail of energy
right it is it was when it came out with
pawns and fleischmann these two
award-winning electrochemists discovered
this effect
at um you know i think it was brigham
and young university
um where they discovered this in utah
and um
they weren't sure what to do with the
effect that they discovered they went to
people in their department
to try and you know what do we do
because like we have a new breakthrough
energy source potentially we could get
shot by the oil companies like how do we
get this out and one of the guys at the
department was actually a guy named
steven jones
i know him i spent a long flight from uh
la to australia with him sitting next to
him yeah so
yeah i've met him before too he's he's
an interesting guy he's got a lot of
papers on muon catalyze fusion and he's
got a lot of
a lot of interesting ideas and stuff but
he yes
cole fusion's the one he's that's the
whole history of it but
what essentially they re coined the term
because this press conference blew up in
their face
they had a bunch of caltech and mit guys
come in and say like oh look
this doesn't exist mit basically wrote
the obituary they wrote an obituary for
cold fusion before they had the data and
the results back from their lab but it's
real real cool can you explain what cold
fusion is
it's now called lattice assisted nuclear
reaction um
because what they they know is happening
is that inside of a lattice of a metal
um these atoms are able to behave
differently than they behave inside
you know a star inside the surface of
the sun where they're fusing so inside
of a metal
you can saturate metal like what they do
is they saturate palladium with tons of
deuterium
the deuterium is like heavy water it's
like you take hydrogen has two isotopes
you add take one hydrogen is just a
proton so if i add a neutron to that
it makes it heavy hydrogen that's called
deuterium if i had two protons that it's
even heavier
neutrons two neutrons and that's called
tritium
right so what they do is they take
deuterium and they pump a ton of it into
this palladium
lattice until they get a saturation of
over 90 percent and then when they hit
that
that saturation point which they proved
the caltech and mit replication
experiments never got up
to that level where they would have even
seen an effect in their labs
but numerous other labs have done this
over the past you know 30 years since
this
and have shown positive results and
there's an international collaboration
of scientists still working on cold
fusion and still researching this i got
a question
so we got to keep going on this yeah
so you put deuterium which is basically
hydrogen with an added neutron so it's
heavier than regular hydrogen yes put it
in a lattice of palladium
yes and then you they because it's
heavier they don't like bounce past each
other they have more of a tendency to
nail each other when they but what do
you do do you vibrate the palladium to
get them to
to fuse well they found that vibrating
the palladium or
shooting it with a laser and what
something called super waves where they
have um
you know multiple frequencies added on
top of the same wave
when they hit them with these sort of
super frequencies uh called super waves
and
or do laser assisted lattice assisted
nuclear reaction
that it increases the effect so there is
some sort of
what we believe is going on is that
there's some sort of entanglement some
sort of coupling between the atoms
inside this lattice when you get a high
enough concentration and get enough of
them packed in
and that allows for fusion to take place
not only does it allow for it
to take place but it also allows for the
the um the gamma
gammas that should be produced in these
reactions that was one of the arguments
that
these reactions should have produced
gamma rays that should have killed these
scientists if they were actually
producing fusion in the laboratory
but they've shown through moss power
effects and brem strolling radiation
that they're actually able to
divide that energy up and release it as
phonons or electronic vibrations to a
lattice to
the lattice so that's essentially how
they convert it into energy that we can
use
but we can't use it because in order to
use energy like that
right in order to build a power plant i
have to make steam that's
what i need so that's how a nuclear
reactor works we we have these controls
oil water
we boil water and then we use that water
to push a tesla turbine
the same technology that tesla invented
so that's crazy phonons to create
piezoelectric uh basically vibrate it
until it creates an electrical charge
it might be a way to do this with cold
fusion where we create smaller voltage
the thing is that we
there there's more research that needs
to be done into turning this into usable
energy because you can build a cold
fusion reactor but if it's cold and it's
not boiling water then you're not going
to be able to produce steam you're not
going to be able to build a power plant
with what is it it's literally cold
isn't it you can touch it like it's not
hot
it's it's just happening cold is i think
a relative term i
i believe it they electrolyze this and
um
they actually try not to make make it
too hot because it will actually fissure
the metal and have other effects
so it takes place cold yes at a much
colder temperature than
so so wait wait you're saying that they
can do it but they just can't
convert the energy in any meaningful way
that's one of the biggest problems right
now they're like now what
yeah so now we we've measured you know
the us navy uh spay war lab actually
measured tritium in their
their cold fusion tests the guy gary
larry forcely
and i met him at mit at the at the
conference
too but these guys have proven that you
know fusion's taking place
there's some other process that they
that's not well understood that accounts
for why
we don't see these high energy gammas
being produced but then there's the
problem of
engineering a power plant out of it
because how do you
you know how do you boil water producing
phonons you boil water
are the phonons vibrating the lattice
where are the phonons going that it's
producing
yeah it's literally it's relaxing that
um vibration to and then distributing it
to a lattice so it's
divided um yeah it's divided among the
lattice so if we can figure out how to
get
energy from vibrating palladium i i keep
thinking of piezoelectric which is just
energy that you get from movement um
then maybe we could get we could have it
vibrate is it moving is it really
it really is moving it's really strange
because it occurs at these
active sites and the materials it only
occurs like it
um cracks in metal appear to be like a
active site where these things um are
appearing and then
you know there's different researchers
on different sites so one guy's saying
that no the cracks are bad and that's
that's not what's going on and then
there's other guys saying that the
cracks are good
and it's just like ladium's interesting
uh element it's the only element
in the entire periodic table that has
its outermost valence shell saturated
with electrons
so it's like electrically repulsive so
it's probably preventing the gamma
radiation
it's pushing that's got a lot of push to
it that explains why why tony stark
replaced his palladium core or why he
had a palladium core in his
uh his arc reactor that's exactly
exactly very similar to cold fusion in
the arc reactor there's a lot of
similarities between the arctic reactor
and coal fusion i'm kind of i'm joking
but like was there is that kind of the
the
inspiration for i don't believe i think
that came
i think that came before of course pawns
and fleischmann iron ban is like the 70s
doesn't it go back no but i mean like in
the modern iterations he's got palladium
in this core then it like generates
electricity of some sort
i'm sure when hollywood was redoing that
film they kind of like they
they consult with people like me because
i've been approached by people in
hollywood like look i'm making a film
and i want like some real science to
kind of like throw in
or something and mix with this that's
realistic and stuff so that happens
i know that happens for sure um so but
you know like i don't know it's it's
weird man so i mean
i can't wait too much but so what we
built we got to build a fusion
functioning fusion generator that
produces electricity
yeah i think these but then i i hear
these crazy conspiracies that oil barons
and you know right the tycoons will come
after them
do you think that's legit like you
mentioned before there are people who
don't want the system to change
and i hear a lot that's actually a very
left-wing talking point the
environmentalists the climate change
activists say
that it's the big oil companies their
banker buddies and the politicians who
don't want to lose that control over the
people
let me a little bit more the general
idea they have
is that we as a people are addicted to
fossil fuels we have built this entire
civilization upon it over the past
hundred plus years
and you you hear from people like greta
tunberg who she says you know we we
don't want to wait till 2030 or 2022 we
want it now we want a moratorium
and that would mean millions would die
yeah because they have no food
production they have no vehicles
and so men on the left think it's the
industrialist doing it on purpose
because so long as we're
addicted to this they can say oh but we
can't get rid of it you'll die
mm-hmm do you think that there's there's
like i've seen so many videos where
they're like i've invented cold fusion
or i've invented infinite energy and
they show like magnets on a wheel
spinning and it's like very ridiculous
but in a more serious tone do you think
that there's prob
there may be scientists who have
developed some maybe you know prominent
renewable type energy or clean energy
that's being suppressed
i'll mention one um you know you
mentioned like
perpetual motion machines i've only seen
one in the literature which
actually might work and it's based on
einstein's brownie in motion
and it's uh i i i that would mean that
more energy is coming out of a system
that was put into it that defies the
laws of physics doesn't it
i sent you a link on it it's it's
basically like it's a quantum effect and
it basically
it exploits the heisenberg uncertainty
principle in
in some ways which is kind of like what
i talk about with these squeeze states
you're squeezing one of those parameters
in the heisenberg uncertainty principle
to make the other one go astronomical so
that you can
you can change its position or its
momentum
in space by by focusing one if you know
one
you can only know the position or the
momentum of an object to within a degree
of h-bar over two pi that's heisenberg
uncertainty principle so if you
know the exact position to to within a
finer
degree of uncertainty than h bar 2 pi
automatically the momentum will just go
astronomical
just because it has to conserve this
this principle and the same thing with
the momentum if you know the exact
momentum then suddenly the position
changes
so you can never nail down where
anything is in quantum mechanics as soon
as you try to it moves on you
have you ever watched uh who killed the
electric car
yes yeah on the saturn so i think that's
what tim is kind of pointing at b
with well the conspiracy conspiracies
there are conspiracies the general
motors streetcar conspiracy was a legit
conspiracy there used to be trolley
systems connecting the entire united
states on the east coast i could take a
trolley from here to new york and
i could pay like a dollar for it but
then they took all the trolleys they
bought out all the trolley systems and
pulled all the cars off the off the
rails
disassembled all the rails all the train
tracks and then no one had any way to
get around so they had to buy cars so
you know i even i i can't get it i can't
even get into the details but i could
vaguely
say that i met individuals that that
created you know
innovations and they were bought out by
big companies and they were told to shut
up and they did and they gave them a big
fat paycheck and a lot of these
companies that these new
advancements would contradict with their
market they just got rid of
even solar panels yeah and especially
when you look at something like you know
the the petrol dollar
in its effects on the world stage
involving saudi arabia
i mean saudi arabia is is an empire in
decline
already but if you look at the world
going off oil
they're they're a country that that
again has a very hard time getting fresh
water
have has a very hard time creating any
kind of vegetation any kind of farmland
uh saudi arabia some people speculate
might even have a nuclear weapon already
so when we're seeing empires in decline
there's a lot of ramifications for that
and that's why there's been
larger theories out there that there is
some kind of bigger conspiracy to make
sure that we stay on
gas that we stay on oil rather than of
course advance towards
free energy or free technology or even
innovations
that are less you know cost inducive and
don't prop up the saudi empire
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you